[Musique]
lewis evans bonjour bonjour frédéric
buch et bonjour bonjour merci d'être
présent sur le plateau de tv 78 vous
êtes on va dire d'abord iv noir voilà
vous êtes musiciens tous les deux vous
avez une chaude actualité lewis vous
êtes musicien comme on dit à l'ats
chanteur compositeur
auditeur je devrai m'y tiens voilà du
thym voilà votre actu c'est un deuxième
album qui sort chez universal le premier
single est sorti en juin il s'appelle
spring l'album en entier sortira en
octobre 2007 et nous avons la primeur de
votre présence et de vos morceaux et
c'est un grand bonheur alors frédéric
budget pourquoi êtes vous là tout
simplement je vous fais la réponse vous
êtes un musicien bien sûr et vous êtes
l'auteur d'un album qui s'appelle pyjama
party mais ça c'était un petit peu
longtemps mais bon il existe toujours et
vous êtes aussi un grand ami de lewis on
peut parler de coup de foudre amical
musicale
absolument je pense qu'on peut dire ça
peut le dire alors disons le et surtout
surtout vous êtes l'arrangeur le
producteur artistique du souper moi si
je me trompe pas vous êtes le producteur
artistique de cet album je n'ai ni
nabeul à sortir voilà donc vous nous
faites la gentillesse d'être là tous les
deux vous allez nous chanter des
extraits vous allez donc accompagné
lewis frédéric avec la guitare et voilà
alors on va remonter un tout petit peu
dans le temps
c'est l'un d'eux l'accent lewis a
devient-il suivant les gens ils disent
que je suis québécois mme allard du fipa
québec match l'anglais cette anglaise où
je suis de liverpool à la basse
liverpool a la balle liverpool one c'est
une très longue histoire
je pense qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
mais vous êtes né en je suis né car le 4
mains soirée 1986 l'année du tigre
alors qu'al ahly 20 filets après il
s'est passé un truc assez singulier pour
un onglet vous avait émigré en france il
y en a plein on achète toutes les
maisons c'est une façon de reconquérir
la france et vous êtes arrivé à donc
voilà donc c'est un peu flou
parce que j'ai des parents qui était
policier catholique oui et ils ont
arrêté là tous les deux la police est ce
qu'ils sont devenus un peu d babos
artiste ait une résidence d'artiste à
liverpool après ils ont décidé sur un
coup de tête d'acheter une caravane et
d'aller si et les routes en france quoi
ont été retirés de la scolarité un peu
est en fait une arrivée en france à onze
ans ok mais vous êtes basé quelque part
c'est dans la revanche dans la manche je
me souviens c'était une maison en bout
on avait vécu pendant un an et demi dans
une caravane
il entrerait et on était très content
parce que nos parents ils ont monté les
revenus dits oui j'ai acheté une maison
quoi un truc à 10000 euros un truc pas
si tu bergère et voilà il a dit on a
acheté une maison j'étais trop content
mais en fait c'était un ancien pour
chérie tu fais pour les cochons sans toi
voilà donc on a un vécu là dedans
pendant encore un an quoi me l'a jamais
vraiment de taper cette maison voilà
donc c'était à saint lô c'était à côté
de saint leu dans un endroit qui
s'appelle le guislain la manche
on a vous êtes un anglo normand c'est ça
après j'ai vécu à cherbourg j'ai fait
les beaux arts de cherbourg gta iv
formation sont des beaux-arts bon allez
bo section peinture section quoi ta
j'étais un peu un charlatan figurent tha
en fait j'avais pas le bain
j'avais pas le vac j'étais viré du lycée
pour des histoires de merde est en fait
en gros je me suis dit comment faire
pour avoir un diplôme et comment faire
pour rio c'est un peu dans la vie donc
j'ai tenté le concours des beaux-arts de
cherbourg qui est un beau hasard un peu
de cas soc toi et je savais que je
pourrais peut-être arrivé là-bas et la
veille je me suis fait des peintures à
l'huile et elles sont coupées entre quoi
je n'ai pas coupé quoi donc qu'ils ont
fait payer que vous avez plein de femmes
sur les noms n'étaient pas secs et
j'étais l'agent des thématiques c'est le
parasitage 20 rebonds et la musique est
là c'est vrai qu'entre temps que la
musique c'est venu j'ai toujours eu un
peu des groupes quand j'étais au lycée
avant c'était un peu pour séduire des
filles traversait ça va ça marchait pas
mal quoi ça marchait pas mal tu es après
anglet la salle fils le petit accent
anglais huawei est en fait après j'ai
rejoint les lanskies à 18 ans voilà
justement ce groupe il a existé dix ans
vous étiez d'un chanteur les lands crise
vous avez
c'est toujours ça y est les sections non
c'est juste que je suis parti en projet
solo il ya deux ans et nous on a tourné
pendant 10 ans avec des lances qu'ils
ont à la chine album on a fait trois
albums et on a voyagé le monde et on
dormait remise et qui était défini comme
comment se définit c'est qu'on dit cold
wave mais on touche au donc est bon là
c'est avec des français nés des gars du
coin il y avait un mec qui était
allemand français n'ont pas d'autant
glenn lockhart et ça a duré pendant dix
ans la et à la fin c'est au début de
compter un peu de succès parce qu'elle
premier album a bien marché mais à la
fin c'était un peu endormi gens à 5 dans
des formules talent tu es toujours
ensemble et j'avais énormément peut qu
énormément la fête
ouais et là je me suis dit voilà c'est
le cas les 31 les trente ans il arrive
croyais sa canne quoi d'accord ça fait
quoi doit se calmer maintenant en
écoutant une magnifique chanson qui donc
le premier single sortie de l'album man
in the bubble qui s'appelle bring on
écoute ça va nous calmer ou pas
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lescure
je
x
je sens
ici
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui tu es
je sens mieux
ellis lui
oui
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
restant
[Musique]
mais
oui
le sommet
qu'ici
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà donc spring le printemps qu'on va
pouvoir écouter tout l'été en attendant
l'automne et le nouvel album
cet album c'est le deuxième chez
universal le premier sage bella alfred
pod ce prix là vous aviez deux duos avec
des
ouais quelques annonces et les
canonnades voilà dans celui ci le tout
nouveau tout frais vous avez des duos
avec juliette armanet donc mais charles
juliet juliette armanet dès que j'ai
repris sur un album que j'avais fait
pendant un livre qui s'appelait jukebox
métal vous avez fait la bande originale
d'un lit voilà et c'était la première
fois que j'avais travail frédéric qui
est ici qu est-ce qui faisait alors
satriani il a fait les arrangements sur
du box rien sur l'album est cité 5 mars
au 5 morceaux
voilà et vous avez aussi parce qu'on
raconte tout on est là pour tous dire
vous avez aussi fait la bande originale
d'un film qui s'appelle j'en ai fait
pleins à ras bord je ne suis plus moi
j'étais resté sur celle de mathieu
kassovitz de plus belle l'invitation
avec nicolas bedos michaël cohen
il a déjà tes yeux
et là il ya embrasse moi qui va sortir
tout ça donc c'est pas que je fais le
bon sens et choisissent les morceaux à
moi qui les prennent dans ce cas déjà
pas mal
ouais c'est cool c'est génial voilà donc
vous êtes rencontrés lors d'un concert
tous les deux vous avez des affinités
particulières au niveau de dégrader des
goûts musicaux
mais en fait on le savait pas on ne
savait pas mais ça ça a bien fonctionné
et en fait on s'est rencontré dans un
concert ont joué tous les deux et je
faisais la première partie en fait j'ai
joué quelques quelques morceaux de jazz
mais c'est une de mes passions voilà du
station je chantais puis la guitare
voilà j'avais repris des standards de
jazz et lewis faisait la deuxième partie
en fait c'était un concert pour pour une
association qui s'appelle mauvaises
moeurs qui lutte contre le cancer des
testicules la prostate
je rigole toujours quand j'entends le
mot testicules cinéma oui
c'est une association importante parce
que c'est une association pour
sensibiliser les hommes contre contre
saleh est en fête
lewis avait pas de voiture et ça c'était
c'était une chance c'est que j'ai est ce
que moi je savais pas que le cancer
s'était pour ça à la base c'est à dire
je me suis rasé propre vie allez vous
allez c'est bon c'est pas facile mais si
vous avez décidé de travailler ensemble
quand vous avez commencé le travail sur
votre deuxième album come on comment ça
s'est passé
frédéric menée chez moi et là on parlait
de musique est vraiment c'est une
histoire incroyable qui s'est passé dans
cette voiture en parler on est est la
droite aime bien ça moi ce que j'aime
bien ça et en fait j'avais j'adorais la
façon qu'ils jouaient la guitare et
crochet arrivé chez moi j'étais avec
foot lâche en train de bosser sur des
morceaux est ce que tu peux passer parce
que moi je pars un gratteux j'arrive à
faire des guitares j'arrive à composer
mais il ya certains trucs que je n'avais
pas le faire et il est arrivé et je
pense deux semaines plus tard le
commande pour du box total on l'avait
fait quoi et on sait pas vraiment quitté
des pluies ont fait d'accord et donc
votre titre si je fais dire c'est donc
producteur artistique qu'on dise que ce
projet a rejoint les producteurs du mil
les billes de l'argent dedans croit la
demande 8 à l'air d'accord donc pour des
millions ça serait mon label d'accord
oui toi oui un rongeur la roja donc
argent ça veut dire quoi ça va coli oui
ça arrive avec ses morceaux voulait fait
écouter à frédéric en fait ça c'est
spontané en fait je compose d'un morceau
qui n'aura mais frédéric il michel la
magie fait la magie c'est à dire que
pour un album par exemple est ce que
vous vous essayez de trouver une ligne
directrice une couleur
je sais pas est-ce que vous tailler un
diamant brut pour le faire miroiter de
toutes ses facettes
c'est exactement ça vers une italienne
c'est exactement exactement ce que
j'allais dire non en fait
lewiston donne assez peu de consignes il
amène une chanson et quelquefois je pars
dans la bonne direction ou alors il me
dit yu nan il faut il faut essayer autre
chose
et puis en fait par essais et erreurs
comme ça on arrive à un résultat
quelquefois il ya eu trois ou quatre
versions de la même chanson et
quelquefois comme spring spring
l'histoire c'est que l'avant veille de
l'enregistrement devait aller en studio
la chanson existait pas il m'a envoyé la
chanson est en fait les arrangements ont
été faits en deux jours et juste comme
comme il fallait et en fait c'est une
chanson travailler de façon de plus
logique est simple
en tout cas c'est le truc con ce mec
comme puis de longueur d'onde quoi vous
êtes en phase
moi je pense qu'on est en france gagne
un temps fou c'est parc fredy knie a
envoyé quelque chose et j'ai dit c'est
hors sujet quoi qu'il arrive jamais
révoqué alors qu'on peut parler de ce
deuxième album on peut comment on le
définit cesse et pauvres se dit popp des
chansons simples et sûres sont simples
on c'est à dire c'est des chansons un
peu à l'ancienne c'est-à-dire il ya
quelques accords les tchèques sont assez
simpliste c'est pas je ne cherche pas
s'il ya des côtés autobiographique
chante parle de mon grand père je parle
de ma famille c'est toujours des choses
que j'ai vécues quelqu'un qui parle des
deux compères se marient shard la
seconde par mara marchon somaliens il
était somalien
ouais bon médecin revient en vrai je
suis métisse ça se voit pas d'étudiants
originaires du côté gallois
et voilà donc la musique je dirais c'est
plus du folk pop un peu psychédélique
quoi
en tout cas je moi de façon je vois la
musique j'essaie de rester dans pas
forcément à faire des choses qui se
passe aujourd'hui mais j'aime bien que
la musique de john 7 côté allait
ressembler garfunkel nostalgique
oui je comprends donc pour vos idoles
que vous étiez enfant c'était
j'imagine les beatles pas du tout moi
c'est jim potache et wayne un grand
chanteur qui me suit depuis très
longtemps c'est leonard cohen s'est
aussi j'adore aussi les mouvements un
peu punk gens gagnent au fort
des beatles bien sûr je vais l'hiver fut
donc c'est dans l'adn c'est dans l'adn
mais c'est beaucoup de choses un peu
j'adore j'adore des eagles ça m'allait
kg 30 ans a avoué ce à quoi
ouais avant je faisais je vais pas dire
j'avais peur des eagles comme enseignant
vous est grand maintenant que j'ai
grandi ici choses et pas deux influences
françaises parce que pardon c'était
quand même en france à partir de 11 ans
non vous êtes resté branché musique en
sol cherche son front ce cépage déjà je
voulais dire pas d'influencé française
ou non entre aura bien ça c'est d'arrêt
pas dur parce que sinon il ya dans le
côté pop machin peut porter sur lui y
est sûre du gain si j'aime bien j'aime
bien on va pas pour chanter pour vous je
parlais avec frédéric aujourd'hui que je
disais j'ai commencé avec côté michel
berger donc tu vois j'ai découvert ça il
ya une semaine
et voilà enfin imprégnée par la france
doit cette suite voilà est juste une
autre question comment est ce que bon
l'album est majoritairement en anglais
certaines chansons une surtout en
français comment vous dites tiens salal
va être en français pourquoi besoin
d'ailleurs qui a le refrain a guère
besoin derrière c'est une chanson de 2 à
prolonger de pardon je m'excuse
à ma copine est comme ma copine et
française ouais je me suis dit c'est
qu'une efficacité en facilement sorti
tard j'ai tellement dépensé d'argent
c'est là que je devais m'excuser
en français et par une chanson qui soit
sur mon album les autres chansons en
anglais
et là je vous propose d'écouter un
deuxième extrait donc de cet album made
in the bubble et c'est love gun on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
[Musique]
ski
tu
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
alors voilà c'était s'était passé tales
of god et lovegame d'un staff jaune ce
qu'on peut parler un peu de votre
inspiration comment ça vient comme vous
mettez à écrire une chanson qu'est ce
qui provoque l'envi le sujet et ses
dents très simplement
j'ai une méthode un mois j'ai eu depuis
assez longtemps
je compose toujours sur une guitare
classique déjà parce que je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui pour moi sommes
bien et qui va très bien avec ma voix je
compose tous les jours ang lee rage tous
les jours discipline way to les gens je
me lève je compose une chanson
après je peux revenir sur la même
chanson pendant trois jours
mais tous les jours je fais de la
musique ça veut dire je me lève je donne
le biberon à ma petite fille et je le
faut aussi h la mettez un calleur va
faire la cia cela et après je compose la
musique et je fais ça aussi l'après midi
et souvent je bois beaucoup de café et
je suis là je mens canapé à cette
tournée on l'enregistré en même temps
sur mon portable ou sur mon ordi et
voilà donc je fais des petites bribes de
chansons sans arrêt et de mélodies où il
parle de texte voilà j'arrive sur les
textes les textes c'est quelque chose de
très spontané chez moi c'est à dire je
couds ça cool commune robinet je chante
je chante et tout de suite il ya des
textes qui vient et j'ai toujours
remarqué au bout d'eux comme morose avec
l'auto écriture à chaque fois que je
chante quelque chose il ya toujours une
chance il ya toujours une tellement
énergique et il ya toujours quelque
chose à ce n'est pas par hasard c'est
papa hasard c'est un peu s'y colle aussi
que c'est un prêt psychologiquement pour
moi quoi ces thérapies une thérapie
ouais je range il s'agissait souvent
c'est tout ça fait peur des femmes parce
que des fois j'ai des potes qui mendient
mais luis cette chanson c'est sur
moi quoi
mais je suis l'agent merde et oleg fois
j'ai pas fait exprès donc voilà et
souvent qu'est ce que je fais c'est
quand j'arrive à composer toutes ces
chansons là qui arrive très vite les
refrains je suis assez fort pour les
mélodies ça vient tout seul spontanée
j'ai pas j'ai pas la chercher pendant
des heures et des heures et des heures
une facilité au fait c'est une facilité
et jeu et ça soit comme ça je pense que
si c'est une question de confiance en
soi ça vient comme ça et je fais
confiance un peu dans la mélodie que je
les fais je ne cherche pas pendant des
heures à le modifier quoique à quel
moment vous ai dit la musique c'est ma
voix c'est mon c'est mon truc c'est je
dirais je pense que c'était vers l'âge
de 25 ans après quand même dix ans après
les lanskies il ya un moment je me suis
dit j'avais tellement de chansons et
avant je faisais pas mal la manche aussi
au sein dans les rues quad dans les rues
de caen cherbourg je pense que quand ils
me connaissaient ils m'ont bien connus
comme quoi il y avait tellement de
chansons que je fais et à ce moment là
dans la rue des gens qui s'arrêtait
qu'ils disaient c'était bien et ce
moment là je me suis dit il ya quelque
chose qui se passe et c'est aussi
quelque chose que j'ai un peu obsessive
avec j'ai besoin de mazières je pense
beaucoup d'artistes ont obsessive ils
ont besoin de faire ça peut-être parce
que je sais que j'ai une peur absolue de
rentrer dans le monde réel qui serait
d'aller dans le secteur social je pense
que j'étais dans un dans un dans un but
j'ai peur de tout j'ai peur et s'est un
peu tous les ans un point années de
survie pour moi c'est faut que je fasse
un album et je survis il faut que je
tourne
parce que je sais que je pourrais pas
vivre dans un autre
et alors juste et donc c'est de la
survie ouais hamas et men in the bubble
c'est ça c'est un peu ça - comment vous
l'expliquez ce titre manu da c'est leur
nom bull je pense que des fois
mais moi je suis assis dans ma bulle
quoi j'ai surtout oued et les amis qui
me connaissent j'ai souvent mon appart
est un peu mon territoire où je viens
pas un ours qui sort pas beaucoup mais
quand je sors c'est waouh c'est viva las
vegas je suis le roi du dubai fois mais
je suis suivant chez moi et je fais un
peu j'avais travaillé je regarde l'amour
entre le lundi soir normal sinon je suis
chez moi ouais je travaille je n'étais
pas forcément de c'est un travail je
gagne ma vie avec ça mais je gagne ma
vie avec 101 mais c'est plutôt une
obsession c'est quelque chose qui me
prend aux trucages quoi ça fait pas
plaisir des fans ça me fait vraiment
chier
vous êtes mal ouais ouais ouais si je le
fais pas ouais je sais pas bien mais pas
si c'est pareil pour toi fred parce que
c'est pareil pour vos frêles l'obsession
l'obsession m'a quitté à un moment donné
c'était un peu une malédiction jusqu'à
un certain âge et
un moment donné même de ma vie j'ai j'ai
pu écouter de musique pendant trois ans
parce que j'analyse est tout et je
voulais et c'était trop et 1
un jour un ami m'a dit mais ça te
prendras et sa marque rim et d'une
manière beaucoup plus cool et très
apaisée très tranquille et en fait j'ai
beaucoup de plaisir à faire ça mais sans
enjeu
non il n'y a pas de conscience il n'y a
pas de pression et je crois que dans ce
métier il faut pas essayer de absolument
de de faire des choses pour que ça ait
du succès pour gagner de l'argent il
faut le faire parce que tout simplement
ça fait confiance et une envie mais ce
n'est plus obsessionnel
voilà c'est fini c'est fini j'ai envie
de vous dire un grand merci pour ce
cadeau que je crois que c'est votre
première télé hein on est trop content
sur tv 78 d'avoir cette primeur
bravo plein de succès déjà spring on va
s'en mettre plein les oreilles
voilà c'est
sur youtube il ya le clip venir voir le
match qu'il faut vous suivre sur
facebook il faut cliquer reliques et oui
parce que j'ai pas mal sur les réseaux
pour moi c'est un peu mon expo quoi
j'aurais besoin
et puis peu après à la rentrée quand on
mène et ne veulent pas sortir annoncé le
23 octobre là vous allez être sur tous
les écrans de toutes les chaînes mais
bon l'important c'est d'abord fêter les
70 g c'est les autres comme le cadeau je
me sens va se quitter en musique avec un
extrait de l'album d'avant ce sein de
2016 2015 qui s'est extrait s'appelle
prod et c'était l'album
[Musique]
oui
mais
[Musique]
enrichi
non
monde
[Applaudissements]
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
je
m
shi
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
justin
c
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sens
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où